another tragic example of soft on crime
policies in America police arresting a
19-year-old gunman who went on a several
hour Rampage in Memphis killing four
people and injuring three all while
streaming the sick act on Facebook and
surprise surprise the per no stranger to
law enforcement court records show a
slew of charges in 2020 he was sentenced
to three years in prison but released
after serving just 11 months in jail and
even the Democratic mayor thinks the
lack sentence is to blame listen
Mr Kelly
served his full three-year sentence
he would still be in prison today
and four of our of our fellow citizens
would still be alive so the charge he
was in for a judge it was it was an
attempted murder charge wasn't it yeah
and they reduced it to an aggravated
assault the Senate the sentence was
three years he came out after 11 months
but you see Tennessee just three months
ago passed a truth in sentencing law and
I found this out when I was first a
judge I would sentence someone to X
number of years and then they'd be
eligible for parole I'd get the request
for parole is D.A and I remember saying
I just I just sentenced that guy there
is not only no truth in sentencing in
Most states in this country there is a
benefit given for good time whatever the
hell that means like if you don't stab
or shiv your neighbor then you've
entitled a good time but in addition to
that if you'll notice an attempted
murder down to an aggravated assault
they're taking plea Bargains like crazy
because they don't want to try cases
just like the Sucker Punch in New York
was an attempted murder now it's down to
a misdemeanor guarantee a misdemeanor
emergency can serve as a year he's not
even going to serve that okay and so now
what we've got to understand is the
criminal justice system is not just
broken from the offenders being released
as soon as they're arrested but it's
broken because of plea Bargains it's
broken because of parole probation you
know when someone's put on probation
everybody thinks oh yeah yeah they're in
touch with a probation officer I got
news for you what they do is if they're
lucky they call up the probation officer
loses him doesn't even bother to file a
violation of probation I mean the whole
system is broken my only question and
I'll end with this is how long it will
take for the pendulum to swing back
where it needs to be and that is where
there's consequences and let me say I'm
sorry I just got to say one more thing
the Memphis case the uh Eliza of
Fletcher case the teacher who was
kidnapped and murdered this guy cleofa
Albertson this guy should never be out
when you look at his history you need to
understand the public needs to
understand there are some people who do
not deserve to live where law-abiding
people live because they have exhibited
so much violence so so much disregard
for the life of other people that they
don't they shouldn't be with us we did
it with pedophiles in New York I fought
for the law in New York so that if
you've got a pedophile who served his
time all right then you say wait a
minute they're pedophiles they're going
to come out and reoffend there's a law
in New York which allows them to put
them into a a secured hospital where
they can't get out because they are so
obsessed they're only going to bless
more children we need to do that with
with these reoffenders so this is a mass
shooting you don't really hear the same
level of left-wing or media outrage
about this for some reason though do you
Greg well you can't because the Dems are
busy creating a fantasy of a civil war
right meanwhile there is a real war
going on on civilians on minorities on
the elderly on Asians it's violent crime
by released violent criminals basically
politicians our political leaders are
playing Russian roulette with the public
they're dropping these bullets into
society and they might hit you who knows
we don't the thing about this we don't
have to Gin up a fantasy War uh you
don't need hyperbole when a woman gets
pushed in front of a Subway that trumps
uh trumpies that trumps you know January
6th I'm sorry we're having January 6
every hour every day we're losing track
of the amount of violence that's going
on there was a machete attack in New
York City I repeat a machete attack in
NYC and it was a repeat attack by an
offender a repeat offender who was
released after a machete attack and she
was only 20. so my question is and it's
like the judges when you start charging
DA's and judges with the crimes that the
people they release commit because you
got to tie the consequences to their
decisions yeah and we uh we know the
judge who was involved we know the D.A
he was involved you don't plead down at
attempting murder one to 11 months Dana
and there was a there was a
election earlier this summer in that
county
for D.A and the more conservative person
lost the race
no I don't know I don't know all the
particulars of that because it's
interesting when you have local crimes
like this one something like what
happened yesterday would and the past
three days
in Memphis would probably have made
national news 20 years ago but now it's
so front and center and you sort of
forget what is it like for if you're
actually living in Memphis Harold Ford
Jr is from Memphis I was talking to him
a little bit last night after all this
news broke and he said my city is broken
it is grieving and it is gripped with
violence and I saw that one of the local
news anchors and Clay Travis reported
she was nearly breaking down in tears
discussing the city's violent crime wave
so I think that one of the things if you
take it back to the political
policy process the Republicans are about
to come out with a new for lack of a
better word contract with America yeah
that's September 19th Kevin McCarthy is
going to release that and I read a
little bit about it yesterday one of the
first tenets of it is restoring national
Safety for law-abiding citizens which I
think is should be absolutely job number
one it would be great if Republicans
could join with Democrats and both be
tough on crime
absolutely that was something that Mayor
Mike Bloomberg was really famous for he
created the Consortium of Mayors and
that was one of the top topics that they
spoke about they talked about gun
violence and they talked about how to
keep our Cities Safe
what's been interesting to track and
I've said this a few times over the last
year is where you see this dichotomy
between what the DA's are saying and
what Mayors are saying or what police
Chiefs are saying and when they're
getting internal pressure from people or
from the same party I wonder if things
are going to start to shift and I do
think that having this clear line
between like what the mayor the
Democratic mayor laid out there this
decision was made to let them out at 11
months and these people are dead because
of that or with what happened in New
York with the Sucker Punch guy with
Kathy hokel had to get up there and fix
what the Bronx D.A had done she didn't
fix it well she did she put it got him
back in jail in a parole violation but
it was because there was this clear line
between a policy it wasn't just we
should be locking everyone up I saw that
Senator cotton you know tweeted that we
have an under incarceration problem I
don't think that people think that but
they think that the wrong people I
definitely do but that's okay that's
just me so it is just you know it's not
I mean the only people Democrats want to
lock up are Republicans that's not true
yes it is look at all they prosecutors
Trump supporters and Trump people amen
look what the D.A here is doing they're
always going after Trump guys
maybe if they stop going after Trump
people they could go after the real
criminals we have to leave it there they
said to myself
up next Barack Obama making a big
comeback just in time for midterm season
I winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now